[Music]
good evening I'm Shannon Bremen for Bret
Baier tonight we begin with a new
warning from President Trump he says
he's perfectly willing to let the
government shutdown again if his border
security plans are not accepted chief
White House correspondent John Roberts
starts us off tonight good evening John
Shannon good evening to you with the
clock ticking down to the March 5th
deadline to get something done on the
dreamers and the government set to run
out of money again on Thursday evening
the president appeared to roll those two
things together into a threat that
seemed to take everyone in Washington by
surprise chairing a meeting on strategy
to confront the notorious Hispanic gang
ms-13 President Trump threw a bomb into
talks in a budget deal saying if he
can't get an agreement on immigration
reform he's happy to have another
government shutdown I would shut it down
over this issue
if we don't straighten that out water we
don't have a country
without borders we don't have a country
so when I shut it down over this issue
yes I can't speak for our great
representatives here but I have a
feeling they may agree with me the
threat came straight out of left field
Democrats have been talking about
insisting a daca deal be in place before
moving ahead with a two-year budget but
on the idea of another shutdown the
president found himself an army of one
speaks for itself
we had one Trump shut down nobody wants
another maybe except him White House
chief of staff John Kelly today warned
Democrats time is running out to get a
deal on daca and immigration reform that
the president is not likely to extend
the deadline past March 5th despite what
the president said in Davos just 12 days
ago will get itself that if we need a
little more time we'll take a little
more time I want to get the problem
solved correctly Kelley also raised
eyebrows when he took a shot at daca
eligible illegal immigrants who haven't
signed up for the program the difference
between 691
were the people that some would say
we're too afraid to sign up others would
say we're too lazy to get off their
asses but they didn't sign up at the
White House briefing today the press
secretary had deflector shields on full
when asked about us we want to solve the
problem on Daka and we want to solve the
border security issue we want to inch
chain migration we want to end the visa
lottery system what we don't want to do
is continue kicking the can down the
road we're focused on actually getting a
solution and frankly I think if
anybody's lazy it's probably Democrats
who aren't showing up to work and aren't
actually getting to the table to make a
deal on this behind the scenes the White
House today began the process of
reviewing the newly received Democratic
memo on FISA abuses its author the
Democratic ranking member of the House
Intelligence Committee said he's
concerned with what the White House may
do with it what I'm more concerned about
Allison is that they make political
redactions that is not redactions to
protect sources or methods which we've
asked the Department of Justice and FBI
to do but redactions to remove
information they think is unfavorable to
the president that could be a real
problem
sources who have read the memo tell Fox
News it contains several references that
go to sources and methods that will
likely need to be redacted Republicans
suspect their inclusion was intentional
to force the White House to make changes
that Democrats could later claim showed
a double standard since the White House
made no changes to the Republican memo
the White House insists the process for
the Democratic memo will be identical to
that of the Republican document he met
with Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen
Stein within the last hour to discuss
some of the differences between the two
memos and we are undergoing the exact
same process that we did with the
previous memo in which it will go
through a full and thorough legal and
national security review Adam Schiff has
already laid down a marker insisting
that any political redactions would show
nothing more than White House
stonewalling forcing him to seek another
venue through which he could release his
memo though it's unlikely such efforts
would bear fruit in time to really
matter Shannon all right John Roberts
live for us in the White House thank you
John